1 2 switch is a pretty strange game but  its latest minigame is the weirdest one  yet I'm Tony and this game spot news  update is switching it up the mini game  in question is called baby and it asks  you to rock a crying baby to sleep  except the baby is the Nintendo switch  yeah anyways one two switch will have 28  minigames total these have a variety of  tasks including quick drawing pistols  guessing how many balls are inside the  joy con via HD Rumble and milking a cow  we played all of those and more so head  over to gamespot to see our full 12  switch impressions one to switch  launches for Nintendo switch on March  third the same day as the hybrid console  itself we'll have plenty of coverage  leading up to and on launch day so keep  an eye on gamespot for more and for all  the biggest Nintendo news you're already  in the right place